bienvenidos a picture in a box una
colaboración entre los estudios de
animación pixar y carn academy yo soy
frank y trabajo en la parte técnica y yo
soy álex trabajo en el área de arte y
las historias pixel in a box es una
introducción a las habilidades
fundamentales que usamos para hacer
nuestras películas hay ejemplos de retos
en la vida real de cómo la idea de un
artista puede crear una oleada de
creatividad técnica y cómo los avances
técnicos pueden inspirar a los artistas
para llevar nuevas ideas a la pantalla
con los seres artistas científicos
animadores programadores escultores todo
tipo de personas y lo padre es que ellos
usan herramientas que tal vez estás
aprendiendo en la escuela pero aquí en
picture in a box puedes ver cómo usamos
esas herramientas para crear cosas
increíbles antes de empezar con estas
lecciones deberías de ver cómo encaja
todo en pixar el verdadero pixel
vamos por aquí
en pixar todos los días trabajamos en
varias fases de muchas películas
pero todo empieza con una idea por
ejemplo 'toy story' pudo haber empezado
así
cuando los niños salen de la habitación
los juguetes cobran vida ves yo siempre
supe que mis juguetes hacían eso
nuestras películas empiezan con una
historia y junto con el director y el
escritor definimos todo lo que pasa
usando dibujos simples es como un cómic
exacto y mientras dibujamos los
diseñadores de producción y su equipo
empiezan a diseñar el mundo y los
personajes
mientras ellos pintan dibujan y esculpe
en nuestros guionistas se van a
editorial en donde juntan todas las
historias y dibujos que creamos
lo sincronizamos añadimos música a
diálogos y efectos de sonido
y conforme estas tomas pasan por cada
fase de producción actualizamos las
escenas una y otra vez y aquí es donde
la ciencia y las matemáticas entran en
acción
que sigue a flujo de trabajo estamos
listos para empezar a hacer la película
que sale en los cines y esto sucede en
un orden específico ahora nuestro
artista técnico decide cómo vamos a
crear la película en la computadora he
trabajado aquí nueve años y aún no tengo
idea de cómo convierte nuestros dibujos
en la película terminada honestamente en
cada película nos apuramos con algo hola
gamer hola oye tú has estado aquí desde
toy story que ha sido difícil en cada
película
bueno en todo history todo déjame
enseñarte en tu historia inventamos todo
el proceso desde cero con monsters
incorporated el pelaje y la ropa en
karts las superficies metálicas
reflejantes en cada película nueva
existe un nuevo reto técnico
en intensamente tuvimos que trabajar con
un personaje hecho de partículas
brillantes y solo para resolver eso
necesitamos de muchas personas
o de qué está hecha su figura estará
hecha de puntos y partículas de luz fue
muy difícil esta es la décimo séptima
versión y los personajes se mueven por
lo que alguien tiene que agregarle
controles a los modelos como una
marioneta no sí excepto porque en lugar
de y los nuestros animadores usan un
programa de computadora para mover a los
personajes en un mundo digital
a continuación en el flujo de trabajo
escenarios
entonces para cars 2 construyeron toda
la ciudad de londres necesitábamos un
gran pedazo de la ciudad porque maté
mcqueen corren a través de ella así que
tuvimos que resolver cómo hacer los
edificios para que se vean lo
suficientemente reales y nos movemos por
el escenario con cámaras virtuales
a continuación animación yo sé que hacen
los animadores ellos le dan vida a los
personajes ves cómo se mueve pero no
tienen cabello ni ropa agregar y mover
estos elementos es el trabajo de alguien
más y se hace después y por alguien más
me refiero a mí ya otros 20 artistas
técnicos de simulación de dónde sacas
esas playeras
tenemos que construir todo lo que ves
incluyendo las texturas y superficies
que ayudan a que el mundo y los
personajes se vean creíbles siguiente
parada en luminación irónicamente el
departamento de iluminación es muy
oscuro
entonces cuando empiezan no hay luces no
cualquier fuente de luz es algo que
tenemos que agregar a la escena nada más
en esta toma hay 230 luces
última parada granja de render una
película en realidad es una serie de
imágenes o fotogramas hay 24 por cada
segundo aquí es donde hacemos los
fotogramas todo se une aquí el arte las
matemáticas y la ciencia un solo
fotograma puede tardar más de 24 horas
en renderizar un solo fotograma y eso es
suponiendo que no surge ningún problema
es increíble ver las tomas finales y
ahora que ya sé cómo se hacen es todavía
más genial ya terminamos el tour el
siguiente paso es regresar a picture in
a box y elegir una elección y tú qué
quieres probar bueno el de construir
robots usando combinatoria se ve muy
bien y qué tal el de escenarios y
montaje lago el de animada los
increíbles increíble yo siempre quise
animar